jeder von euch kennt einen soziopathen
vielleicht bist du mit einem sozi paten
befreundet vielleicht sogar mit ihm
zusammen
freunde der sonne das hier ist ein recht
spontane reaktion video und zwar auf 10
dorstens aktuelle serien es kann sein
dass es nicht sagt weil er ein
amerikanischer youtuber ist aber im
englischsprachigen raum zählt zu den
größten youtube würde ich sagen er ist
derzeit bekannt für mehrteilige youtube
doku serien wie zum beispiel auch ganz
gerne mal kontroverse youtube
persönlichkeiten porträtiert und sein
ziel dabei ist es meine andere seite von
diesem menschen zu zeigen die kehrseite
der medaille die man als zuschauer so
bei youtube normalerweise nicht sieht
deine aktuelle achtteilige serie dreht
sich um jd power beam das nichts sagt
jake paul ist der jüngere bruder von
logan paul und bei logan paul sollte ist
bei den meisten klingeln das ist nämlich
der typ mit dem zurzeit forest skandal
chains serie dreht sich um die frage ob
jack paul ein zuzug pakt ist und in
folge zwei die inzwischen was mir
schauen 17 millionen menschen gesehen
haben besucht stehen eine psychologin um
von ihr erklärt zu bekommen wie man
einen soziopathen erkennt das buch aus
dem hier vorgelesen wird ist das dsm 5
spricht die aktuelle und fünfte auflage
des diagnostik entwickelt annual of
mental disorders ihm die es sind fünf
stehen alle anerkannten psychischen
störungen und erkrankungen und deren
klassifizierung so hier geht es um
antisoziale persönlichkeitsstörung auch
bezeichnet als psychopathie soziopath
oder dissoziale persönlichkeitsstörung
ich lese euch mal vor was die
diagnostischen kriterien sind für eine
antisoziale persönlichkeitsstörung laut
die es im 5er das versagen sich in bezug
auf gesetz mäßiges verhalten
gesellschaftlichen normen anzupassen
dass ich in wiederholten begehen von
handlungen äußert die einen grund für
eine festnahme
zerstörung fremden eigentums belästigung
anderer personen diebstahl oder ausübung
illegaler tätig zweitens falschheit die
sich äußert ihnen wiederholtem lügen den
gebrauch von decknamen oder dem
betrügenden anderer zum persönlichen
vorteil oder vergnügen incentives können
sein geld sex macht drittens
impulsivität oder versagen
vorausschauend zu planen
das kann sich äußern in unvermittelt im
wechsel des arbeitsplatzes der wohnung
oder des partners viertens reizbarkeit
und aggressivität die sich in
wiederholten schlägereien oder
überfällen äußert fünftens
rücksichtsloser missachtung der eigenen
sicherheit oder der sicherheit anderer
das kann sich zum beispiel äußern in dem
fahrverhalten also wiederholte raserei
trunkenheit am steuer häufung von
autounfällen sechs durchgängige
verantwortungslosigkeit die sich im
wiederholten versagen zeigt eine
dauerhafte tätigkeit auszuüben oder
finanziellen verpflichtungen
nachzukommen und siebter fehlende reue
die sich in gleichgültigkeit oder
rationalisierung also sprich
selbstrechtfertigung äußert wenn die
person andere menschen gekränkt
misshandelt oder bestohlen hat außerdem
äußert sich so eine antisoziale
persönlichkeitsstörung
so steht hier häufig durch das fehlen
von empathie also die fähigkeit sich in
andere menschen hineinzuversetzen mit
seinen mitmenschen mitzufühlen so damit
hätte ich jetzt shanes 45 minuten langes
video abgedeckt denn inhaltlich passiert
nicht mehr als das was ich euch gerade
erzählt habe die psychologen liest aus
dem dsm 5 vor
genau das was ich gerade vorgelesen habe
nur mit sehr viel drama
[Musik]
die kripo 6 mio
johnstons auf ok falls ihr shanes um
erst mal schaut muss man vielleicht dazu
sagen dass dieses überzogene drama so
sein stil ist der normalerweise mit so
einem gewissen augenzwinkern und bewusst
übertrieben serviert nur in kombi mit
diesem thema finde ich hat er sich doch
irgendwie im ton vergriffen weil das für
mich jetzt nicht irgendwie übertrieben
humorvoll wirkt sondern einfach nur
dramatisch und angsteinflößend
wir haben
um es genau zu nehmen sind es
schätzungsweise 0,2 bis 3,3 prozent der
bevölkerung sprich im zweifelsfall nur
einer in 500 beziehungsweise bis zu
einer in 30 und ja wenn es 31 sind dann
ist es ziemlich sicher dass jeder von
uns einen soziopathen kennt das ist
problematisch finde ich dass er sich
hier mit einer expertin zusammengesetzt
hat die aus dem dsm 5 vorliest was dem
ganzen einen sehr wissenschaftlichen
rahmen gibt aber nicht nur die der
schnitt des videos und die musik sondern
auch aussagen wie er soll ist mir kalt
den rücken runter und ich hab personen
schlechtes gefühl im bauch mit diesen
menschen das sind alles natürlich
unglaublich unwissenschaftliche aussagen
ich kann nur ständig wiederholen alles
psychologische ist auch gleichzeitig
biologisch und es gibt ein sehr extremes
beispiel dafür und das ist der fall des
fingers gates geht war ein freundlicher
höflicher zuverlässiger junger mann der
im jahr 1848 einen schrecklichen unfall
erlitt bei dem sein vorderes hierdurch
bord wurde erstaunlicherweise überlebte
er
und noch ein bisschen erstaunlicherweise
überlebte er als anderer mensch er war
kognitiv also er war genauso intelligent
wie vorher aber er weiß plötzlich ein
impulsives arschloch dass ihr euch zum
beispiel für die neurologie nach dem
ganzen interessiert wir haben mal für
schön schlau so eine kleine reihe
gemacht zu dunklen triade nazismus
makler willis und psychopathie und die
verlinke ich könnt ihr euch nochmal
anschauen ich möchte an dieser stelle
aber noch drei sachen ergänzen die ich
sehr wichtig finde
moment hey du bist wieder zu früh aber
wir haben doch das wichtigen moment ja
ich weiß aber wir machen das immer in
der endart ich komme gleich nochmal
sorry erstens nichts alle soziopathen
oder psychopathen sind böse also unter
serienmördern zum beispiel gibt es einen
ganz hohen anteil am psychopathen
beziehungsweise so zu parken
aber umgekehrt heißt das nicht dass
jeder psychopath auch ein serienmörder
ist ein sehr interessantes beispiel ist
der neurowissenschaftler james fällen
der zufälligerweise im rahmen seiner
arbeit
herausgefunden hat dass er selbst ein
waschechter psychopath ist wie er im
buche steht er hatte die entsprechende
hier in physiologie er hatte
entsprechende risiko gene und er gab
auch selbst zu im alltag manchmal so ein
bisschen archiv unterwegs zu sein
er selbst meint das auch ganz viel mit
der besonderen liebe und zuneigung zu
tun hat als kind genossen hat und mir
somit gehört ist in der liveshow damit
komme ich direkt zum zweiten punkt 2 so
was ist der unterschied zwischen
psychopathie und so zur partie im dsm 5
wird kein unterschied gemacht und
psychologen sind sich auch nicht ganz
einig manche sagen man sollte das gar
nicht unterscheiden oder kann ich andere
benutzen ganz bewusst psychopathie wenn
sie auf genetischen ursprung hinweisen
möchten und soziopath ii wenn sie auf
erlernten ursprung hinweisen möchten zum
beispiel es gab ein trauma in der
kindheit oder eine frühe misshandlung
die dazu geführt hat
jetzt weiß man aber dass gene und umwelt
eigentlich nicht zu trennen sind also
alles was mit psychologie und mit
verhalten zu tun hat ist sowohl
genetische als auch umweltbedingte und
zwar oft sehr stark miteinander
verknüpft beispiel es gibt das so
genannte variante dass krieger gehen
wenn ich diese genvariationen habe und
dann noch in meiner kindheit ein
traumatisches erlebnis er leide oder
misshandelt werde dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich eine
psychopathie entwickelt sehr hoch wenn
ich aber nur dieses virgin habe oder nur
misshandelt werde oder traumatische
erlebnisse leide dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit jeweils zur
psychopathie nicht zu hoch nur die
kombination drittens nicht alle
psychopathen oder soziopathen sind
geniale manipulative genießt die welt
wie ein marionettenspieler unter
kontrolle haben viele betroffene leiden
zum beispiel unter arbeitslosigkeit oder
haben gar kein richtiges soziales umfeld
es gibt natürlich auch hoch intelligente
psychopathen die dann besonders
manipulativ und gefährlich sind aber das
ist dann schon eher das bild das wir aus
filmen oder
von den medien kennen helens video
behandelt soziopath ironischerweise auch
brecht und empathisch was ja eigentlich
das ding von soziopathen ist aber so
sympathische menschen werden hier als
unmenschlich dargestellt so als kalte
maschinen und damit wird so ein klischee
bedient was schäden mit einer reichweite
von 17 millionen menschen vielleicht
etwas sensibler angehen könnte müsste es
gab auch viel konstruktive kritik ist
waren wirklich gute kommentare unter dem
video andere youtuber haben darauf
reagiert und eine sehr valide kritik ist
zum beispiel dass man für eine
professionelle psychologische diagnose
nicht einfach das dsm 5 nehmen kann und
sich ein paar youtube videos anschauen
kann und dann direkt los abgeben kann
shane ist sehr gut mit der kritik
umgegangen wie ich finde er hat sich
ernst genommen hat sich auch in folge
drei dafür entschuldigt und auch die
nächsten folgen entsprechend
umgeschnitten
um das zu berücksichtigen und auch wenn
sie schon im ton vergriffen hat finde
ich diese diskussion die gerade hier
entsteht im amerikanischen englischen
youtube erstaunlich konstruktiv und sehr
wertvoll und weil ich psychische
gesundheit auch sehr wichtig finde und
das auch so ein teil unserer gesundheit
ist der so oft übersehen wird dachte ich
ich beteilige mich jetzt hier mit einer
diskussion und bringen sie auch rüber
nach deutschland findet ihr mann sollte
über psychische störungen und
erkrankungen besser aufklären und gibt
es eine spezielle psychische erkrankung
oder störung über dir gerne mehr
erfahren würdet und die wir hier bei
meidet mal in einem extra video
behandeln könnten wenn ja schreibe es in
die kommentare
und jetzt kommt die end karte wurde für
den fast v1 wettbewerb nominiert und es
gibt einen publikumspreis
möchtet könnt ihr uns helfen unter
diesem video florida verhalten das
gehirn zählen bis zum 14 oktober jeder
leid und jeder kommentar und jeder
kommentar der eine diskussion anstößt
zählt doppelt
[Musik]